[Music]
hi everybody so this will be our last
video from parasite and I would say the
most important one because we will be
talking about irony
remember irony is your best friend in
your screenwriting process you can use
it in your logline for your characters
for the scenes almost anywhere in your
screenplay and I'm sure we will talk a
lot about irony in our next videos
because all the best films are permeated
with irony in screenplays two types of
ironies are mostly used dramatic irony
and situational irony in this video we
will talk about dramatic irony in the
simplest of terms dramatic irony exists
when the audience knows a key piece of
information that the main characters do
not know or in other words the audience
is aware of what's going on in a certain
situation where the characters are
unaware of what is happening if you
create a smart dramatic irony situation
you will automatically build tension
create suspense and even comedy in your
screenplay so use this device as much as
you can because it will take your
writing to the next level now let's take
a look at three examples of dramatic
irony in parasite first the Kings
credentials and infiltration into parks
family-run reducible the Kings entire
path to employment in the parks house is
based on deception each of them pretends
to be highly qualified for the position
in question and do not disclose their
relation to one another therefore their
employment in the house creates a
heightened instance of dramatic irony in
which we know something
the parks do not second the housekeeper
and the drivers dismissals these guys go
to the memorial since a mangaka Vassallo
the keeps manipulate the parks into
firing both the housekeeper and the
driver so that key tag and chunk soup
can take over their positions in this
situation the viewer knows that
Kym's are fabricating the rationales for
the firings but the parts do not
additionally not that the housekeeper
nor the driver now why they are getting
fired but the viewer does third the
Keim's are inside the house chrome to
cut in devotion Gong kayo I will only
live in when the parks return home
unexpectedly from the camping trip they
have no idea about the violence or the
decadence that has taken place in their
home as far as they know Jung sook has
been quietly tending the home while they
were away the viewer knows that it was
quite the contrary however and that not
only are the housekeeper and her husband
trapped in the underground bunker about
to each the parks also know nothing
about but the Kim's are still there as
well hiding in various locations waiting
for the parks to go to bed then mr. and
mrs. Park go sleep on the couch and mr.
Park is talking about how Mr Kim smells
he is unaware of course that mr. Kim
is hearing him saying that while the
Kim's are hiding under the table but we
the audience are aware of all that
information this is dramatic irony at
its best
so with dramatic irony we are ending the
parasite series on this channel but we
made another video about situational
irony which is available on our patreon
page on our patreon page you will also
find eight extra tips from pulp fiction
and for extra tips from Goodfellas that
we don't share anywhere else the link to
our patreon page is in the description
below let us know in the comments which
tip from parasite was your favorite and
from which films you would like to learn
screenwriting tips in our future videos
keep writing and see you in the next
video